now there's lots of things you can do to
this to try and get it toward that I'm
going to walk you through something
which I've learned from experience and
you will gain as well because we have
believed me lots of examples for your
work through what's the most efficient
wave to get me from here to here or what
are the differences between the two
left-hand sides can you see what the
differences are it's just a factor of
two that plus one in the index just
means multiply it by two one more time
so I'm going to multiply both sides by
two is that okay like so yeah so that's
that now what can I do with this how do
I show that this is actually going to be
this thing here greater then this thing
hmm
so you'd have to write this but what's
happening in my mind is I want to prove
that this is greater than this this is
me with my eyes on the prize this is
where I'm trying to go okay so here's
what I'm going to do I'm going to say
see this it's got a 3k squared in it
right
tucked inside there can you see why I
can I'm going to do that why might that
be a useful thing to do why do I say
three K squared for instance and not for
K squared or two K squared or five
queries even though all those are in
there why might three K squared be
something useful to me it looks similar
three K squared looks similar to this
thing right in fact I'm thinking your
head I know that this you know what k
plus one all squared is right think
about what it is when you multiply it by
three and looks like this three K
squared + 6 k plus 3 do you agree that's
what it's going to look like well I've
already got a 3 K squared in here so I
can say this is that ok now what I'm
comparing is this object here with this
object here do you see that I've gotten
the 3 K squared out of the way I've
dealt with that now these are the bits
that are different hmm
tastes weird I want you to think about
this 3k squared with me okay how can I
show that it's bigger than 6k plus three
hmm hmm think for a moment I'm actually
going to pause here because this is such
an important moment for you to actually
not just be shown the answer but to
think about it because their thinking is
what gets you to learn something right I
want you to remember that K because we
keep saying this all over and over again
k is not just any number right k is not
just any number it's a particular kind
of number I'm not going to say much more
than that because the rest of it is
there on the board so my question to you
and I'm gonna give you about half a
minute maybe I mean also to think about
this why is it that that the fact that K
is not just any number it's a particular
number with particular properties why
might that be useful in proving that
this is bigger than this I want you to
have a think about it and then I'll show
you what it looks like on the board
think really hard so tell me what kind
of number K is you don't know all that
much about it to be honest what do you
know about it it's it's it's a positive
integer and it's greater than or equal
to a and that's pretty much it so at
least you know you don't have heaps of
different things you've got to use but
just like in using the assumption you
have to use this fact part of the way
you know that is did you notice that
three K squared it's not always bigger
than six k plus three three K squared is
a parabola right six k plus three is a
straight line they look to me something
like this here's three K squared 6 K
plus it will be something like this
wouldn't it I'm suggesting the parabola
is bigger than the straight line but it
isn't always it's only when K is greater
than or equal to 8 so I'm gonna have to
use this fact in some way okay now have
a look see how I've got a K squared in
there
okay squared how could I manipulate this
in such a way so that there was a K
squared in there what could I do to both
sides of this inequality okay I could
square both sides but just be careful
when you had a look at the inequalities
right
squaring both sides is something which
is nice and safe when you've got
equations right but even then it's a bit
dicey right because these two lines are
not a hundred percent equivalent are
they right squaring actually introduces
solutions and makes it a little more
complicated there's another thing you
could do which seems like the same thing
but I'm rather than squaring both sides
I'm going to multiply both sides by K
that makes this K squared you're like
didn't you just square both sides no
idea what's the right heads are gonna
become eight K now this is an equality
in equations you can multiply both sides
of an equation by anything you like and
everything stays the same you can't
always do that with inequalities right
sometimes when you multiply things it
changes the direction in equality how do
you know when it changes and when it
doesn't like say this is true right but
I can multiply both sides of this
inequality by a whole variety of
different things and the direction of
the inequality will be changed if I'm
multiplied by a negative the inequality
is no longer facing in that direction is
it it's going to be like that yes so how
do I know the inequality hasn't changed
what do I multiply by again I multiplied
by K and I know K is not just any kind
of number K is a positive integer so the
direction of the inequality is preserved
are you okay with that yes okay now see
there's K squared there I know something
about K squared I can put that in here
where I have a K squared you notice that
so I'm gonna write it like so
do you see why I can do that right this
thing is bigger right
than this thing that's what I just said
over here right
so therefore what you end up with is
smaller when you do this substitution
and that's okay
this site is supposed to be smaller
that's what the direction of the
inequality says how's your brain going
right it's weird this is inequalities
you can just change things when you're
supposed to because the right-hand side
is different okay let me tease this out
of them more for you I've got the 3k
squared at the front that I wanted I
also want a 6k is there 6k in here you
bet this 6k in there there's 24 K in
there so I'm gonna take six of them out
because those are the six I need how
many are left over there are 24 in here
and I've taken six out what are we
saying about algebra earlier today okay
I've got 18 lots of K left over yes now
have a look at this right you know how
you said you told me k was bigger than 8
right K is bigger than 8 so therefore it
stands to reason that this K I can
substitute it for 8 because this is
bigger than this I'm getting smaller and
smaller and smaller as I go down do you
see that every time I'm sitting for
something that is smaller yep what is 18
times 8 I'm not great with my 8 times
tables 9 times 8 is 72 so that's 144
what did I want over here
I didn't 144 actually I wanted 3 is
there 3 in 144 and you bet there is
there's a lot more than three right do
you see what I've just established do
you see what I've done this is now see
this thing why was I trying to why was i
twisting and turning this thing because
this is three outside of K plus 1
squared plus something else which of
which I don't really care what it is so
long as I'm adding something that's
positive right well this is clearly
bigger than this right do you see how I
keep on getting smaller and I've still
maintained
and the validity of the statement - so
the K + 1 I'm done I'm finished that is
the statement as what we're trying to
prove for N equals k plus 1 there's the
K plus 1
there's the k plus 1 I'm home ok so yeah
it's tricky how's your brain your brain
feels the way a gymnasts body feels
after they're learning and you move and
they're like ah my muscles aren't meant
to do that but they will be able to do
that as you work on these things and
become more familiar with this process
okay so give yourself a bit of time
you've got loads of examples in there